now are you feeling lucky well people
have been warned to buy their online
lotto tickets as soon as possible to
avoid a last-minute rush tonight's
winner could be the biggest ever in the
UK a record-breaking prize of 57 point 8
million pounds which is built up after a
marathon 14 roll overs must be won today
so what are your chances well since
October it's been harder to win the
National Lottery the number of balls
used in each draw increased from 49 to
59 since then it's been about three
times harder to match all six numbers
under the old system the odds were a
mere 14 million to one just greater than
your chances of becoming a professional
astronaut with this new lottery it's now
45 million to one meaning you're about
twice as likely to be made a saint to
compensate Camelot has guaranteed that
at least two millionaires each week and
20 winners of a 20,000 pound prize and
of course if you don't win the jackpot
tonight and face it you're not very
likely to then if you match just two
numbers you'd at least win a lucky dip
ticket for a future draw so let's talk a
little bit more about the probabilities
and depressed ourselves really if we've
got to take it dr. Emily Grossman is a
science and maths broadcaster and
educator and expert on the Ducks duck
quacks don't echo that's really cold
isn't it
she's here to explain a little bit more
so run us through someone's sitting at
home with a ticket and a half inning
really hopeful should they really feel
hopeful they win that big jackpot okay
so the chance of running the actual
jackpot as you said is one in 45 million
now the way that that comes about is
that because we've got 59 balls for the
first ball that's picked out there's 59
to choose from and you've got six
numbers that six out of 59 then five out
of 58 four out of 57 and so on down so
it comes out if you times those all
together those fractions that becomes
one in 45 million it's actually more
likely as you said that you could become
an astronaut that you could be hit by
lightning that you would have done a few
drawings you to illustrate you know you
can imagine for lightning before times
more likely that you'd get hit by
lightning than winning the jackpot
tonight unfortunately or that you could
have identical quadruplets and orbit by
hit by falling debris from a plane but
there is some good news because the
whole point of this roll over because it
because it's gone
over 50 million now what that means is
that somebody has to win or some people
should have to share that prize so if no
one wins the actual jackpot which is
possible it could roll down to the next
level which is 5 balls plus the bonus
now we're 6 times more likely to win at
5 balls plus bonus because you've
effectively you're choosing 6 balls but
out of 7 options this time so use
effectively buying 6 different versions
of the lottery ticket with your 1 ticket
so that means that it's now a 7 and 1/2
million chance to run we talked to one
of winning but it is still more likely
unfortunately that you would be eaten
alive by flesh-eating bacteria you would
die falling off a ladder falling out of
bed or drowning in the bath then very
touchable option so that you would get a
gold in the Olympics is it affected by
the fact that there are huge number of
people who are seeing the big jackpot
and thinking I'm gonna buy a ticket when
they normally wouldn't will there be
more people buying tickets how does that
affect so it doesn't affect the chance
is the odds of actually winning but what
it does affect is how many people you'd
have to share it between so the more
people who buy the more likely you are
to have to share that prize but it is
definitely still worth buying tickets
because no matter what happens you've
got a 1 in roughly 9 chance of winning
something which is pretty good so it's a
chance to play again even if it's just
to just play again and of course all the
money that people spend on tickets a lot
of it does go to funding really great
projects so it's definitely worth using
of course and it has got harder
generally hasn't it those changes
they've got more balls to choose from
exactly which as you said makes it 3
times less likely to win the jackpot and
in fact that there is still relatively
good chance there's still more chance
than for example dying by falling
coconut or dying by being crushed by a
vending machine oh that's such a smile
on your face do you know what I haven't
but any gonna get together buy one now
by talking through some extraordinary oh
yeah enemy at gross Emily Grossman
lovely to see you thanks very much